hey i'm moses storm and this is my first
time on conan presented by samuel adams
let's watch it this was September 25th
2017 by the way I ran out there because
I missed the cue I thought because he
was like and I was like so ready to go
that I ran out like a psycho and then I
come out no Mike my mom was a single
parent five kids no child support and a
lot of people find that hard to believe
that I was ever that poor I think it's
because the way I look like I look like
everything just like worked out in fact
I look like the guy in the movie that
yells that one part was not supposed to
get a laugh the worked out was just
setting it up so once I heard that I was
like oh this is great I lucked out on
this night the crowd was feeling really
good the the audience
warm up got that warms up Conan's show
was incredible so he got them so excited
that when I by the time I got in there I
felt great
going into this usually for a late night
set you have a lot of time to prepare
the set and run it a bunch of times so
you know it like the back of your hand I
couldn't I at the time of this taping I
was living in Utah for two months to
shoot this teen drama show on YouTube
read YouTube read is great you've ever
been on YouTube and you thought I wish I
was paying for this and there was one
club that I could run an ad it was
called wise guys and they were like
you're here again
so I ran this at maybe twice three times
before doing it on TV so I felt very
underprepared but I think it did help me
be a little bit looser don't you know
who my father is
also this suit is from Utah
I am NOT an adult I did not have
anything that was not like oh vans and
like a flannel shirt and then my friend
Jack not you actually I brought with me
to the show was roasting me because I
wanted to wear white fans with this suit
because I thought that would be cool and
he said no you're gonna be on TV
wear shoes like a grown man loved Jack
night and I legitimately don't didn't
get a last important to point that out
while we're Tooting my horn this whole
night there's a little tag on there what
I'm like I don't know who my dad is
didn't get a laugh because I have was
just trying to like barrel through it
and make time and I didn't wait for the
applause to die down or it just wasn't
funny but yes didn't get a laugh so then
I cover it here you miss out on certain
things look now I'm just explaining it
and like huh what if my dad sees this
and I'm like apologizing I said don't do
that just do your joke this is a poor
kid like we never had ice cream growing
up the closest thing we had hmm who's
never drank before an alien like that is
every once in a while my mom would buy
us that like giant clear value bucket of
ice cream do you remember those but they
were like too cheap to even be a real
flavor we have white and we have darker
white
this is true my mom only bought us that
a good example of the audience one guy
doing a great job at the top of the show
that never gets an applause break and
has since never gotten an applause break
so hot crowd I lucked out I scream
because she needed the bucket this part
never never got applause and applause at
Walmart a mopping bucket caused $6.99
value bucket of ice cream $4.99 it was
cheaper than an empty bucket do you know
how shitty your ice cream has to be
great to actually depreciate the value
of an empty bucket that means people
were like I don't want that bucket if
ice creams been in there it might ruin
my dirty mop water some food duck love
that joke
till this day just because it was like
two weeks old when I shot this usually a
set you're doing it's like you've been
doing this for nine years you know this
joke works I had written that a month
before sent the book or the tape and
then that was just to get into this
other food material but he said do that
yeah I wish I could still do that I wish
it wasn't burnt and on TV yeah right new
stuff way too expensive who the hell
does avvocato think it is you know we
grow those here right yet every
restaurant you go into avocados like
guys just so you know I'm always a
dollar extra oh sure sure sure
fun facts about this is this is exactly
what I do at my hotel
every night I watch this exact set I
stand as close to a hot light bulb like
a moth and I just drink I'm great you
could just buy me in the store this is
is this is the part I get the most
comments on when I turn my back to the
audience apparently that is a big no-no
in comedy luckily it worked out people
are like that's a lot of confidence to
turn your back on the crowd you should
never turn your back on the crowd you I
can't believe it you were a genius you
thought it worked out I literally just
didn't think about it and turned away
from the crowd but you're not supposed
to do that don't do that but even then
you really can't eat me until I'm ready
also didn't have time to tailor the suit
so another comment section I get is that
the pants are flat pants so it's all
like the YouTube comments are mainly
positive and this is the first thing
I've ever gotten positive YouTube
comments on and so all the YouTube
comments are very nice thank you for
those this guy looks like King Joffrey
avocado be like that and then the rest
but ninety thousand are just like flawed
bags
where's the flawed where's Moses and his
plugins like that's no it's a different
Bible reference Oh what's he tazeed
goochie goo did you just fall asleep for
10 minutes because in that time I've
taken it upon myself to go ahead and die
yes now I taste like wet car keys
meanwhile bananas only grow in Central
America they cost negative 11 cents you
make money buying bananas so I just
wrapping this up this is this is a very
fun set it went surprisingly better than
I thought and I knew it went well
because after the set conan said one of
the meanest things in the world and if
you feel like any young design that's
that well he's like very nice and once
you feel good about the show so that's
great but i knew i did well because it's
a blur but after the set i sat down and
called over do you mean he goes it was
great shame nothing that's gonna air and
I was like yes I did it that was great
and then was just happy just to skate by
on the show and then the next day a
friend sent me a reddit link and this
this set had made it to the front page
of Reddit and legitimately for the past
years was like just past the one-year
mark this set has been paying my bills
it's every comedy club I've ever wanted
to play
people will have wanted to meet the
heroes of mind have seen this set we
should do something it's like the 1970s
where it's like what's gonna happen to
me because like someone you always hear
like these late-night sets
I like but these don't make you or break
you no one really watches these anymore
it's not like it was in the seventies
for me personally this was like a
complete life-changing moment like from
this set on it is completely different
before this I was touring and headlining
America's worst comedy club slash casino
slash bowling alley slash you have to be
out of 10 p.m. because we immediately
turn this over to alack be a dance night
after this I got to play great clubs and
I think that this is what got me on this
tour right now
so thank you for watching thank you for
having me on the show Conan and thank
you to Samuel Adams that was my first
time I'm coming